BuzzFeed released a video yesterday I
believe right yesterday they released a
video yesterday on abortion a
pro-abortion video now let me say
something
whether you're pro-life pro-choice let's
leave it at the door here and just
actually try to dissect the information
that BuzzFeed puts out in trying to lay
the framework for their case supporting
not only abortion but modern progressive
abortion policy so let's let's play this
and we'll keep a running talk in reality
there's no average when it comes to
abortion okay each person has their own
reasons circumstances I don't in facts
and such as generalize look at who when
and why people have abortions hmm the
majority of women receiving abortions
are not teenagers she is most likely a
mother with almost 60% of those seeking
a horrible mother comforting apparently
so it belongs
common reasons that our courses include
financial concerns and the pregnancies
interference with work okay it's time
for the liberal lexicon interference is
what they use their the term
interference actually means a baby who
was inconvenient Oh important sex our
power I hear that I find really I very
telling they admit that the abortions
come from issues that relate to finances
or being inconvenient because it
interferes with wanting to work or go to
school okay they say that's the majority
of by the way not gay Jeremy the point
imagine being this woman who has an
abortion her other kid yeah they're
already mothers which means they've had
a kid before what kind of legacy right
like hey I love you yes those special
must never have another mommy do you
love me yes I agree you're our greatest
blessing Oh looks like you're going to
have another boy and here's something
else that I find really telling before
we're going to get into the fact that
they try and present and why they're not
necessarily entirely accurate but no
mention here
women having abortions because they're
unable to afford birth control or didn't
know what it is they say the vast
majority of women are people who are
already mothers who didn't want to have
an inconvenient baby they only say you
know people don't know about birth
control or they can't afford it when
they're talking to black audiences again
because they're talking down to them as
you look into the roots of Planned
Parenthood saying or they don't believe
that the capable of making their own
decisions because they want them back in
the plantation but let's continue with
some more facts they present data from
2013 shows that a majority of abortions
happen in the first eight weeks of the
pregnancy absolutely the embryo is
approximately as large as a pencil
eraser and all those are very small and
I can even heart by six weeks this is
from the great College of Obstetricians
and Gynaecologists reported in 2010 that
before 24 weeks a fetus cannot feel pain
they willingly admit at 6 weeks if you
have an abortion you're stopping a heart
okay that is a heartbeat separate from
your heartbeat as a mother okay she'll
say I hands off my vagina no no time in
a heartbeat so you're not you it's no
longer hands on your vagina it's hands
off this heart beat that's not mine
there's no other way to slice it you are
stopping a heartbeat and that heartbeat
is scientifically and medically 100 it's
not your heartbeat whose heart are you
stopping and that's the question that
you have to answer it if you just say
it's an inconvenient heartbeat fine then
they go on to say that up to 24 weeks
that these babies can feel no pain well
there's conflicting evidence so I'm
unlike BuzzFeed I'm not going to say
definitively that this is we know this
to be a hundred percent room but by 18
weeks pain receptors throughout the body
are developed and then there are some
studies that show earliest reactions to
stimuli can be detected at five point
five weeks after fertilization what they
mean is they'll still offer some
stimulation to the baby in the womb and
then repeat it and you'll see the fetus
in the womb actually try and get away
from the unpleasant stimuli now I can't
say a hundred percent that it's
conclusive that these babies can feel
pain but there's a lot of evidence to
suggest that they can and it has a
beating heartbeat so at that point when
we're saying gosh maybe they can feel
pain and we do know that there's a
separate heartbeat should we err on the
side of maybe not harming or killing the
baby I don't know it's just meat let's
continue and see if they address that
operation is the most common method of
in clinic abortions the procedure is
performed by opening the cervix wide
enough to be able to use suction to
remove the pregnancy talking about lazy
yeah they couldn't image search large
like the drawing it is not positive
music never you PI I don't know that's
two percent of that pie and less than
two percent of the abortions and major
complications happen very rarely there
are more complications at a higher risk
of death bringing a baby to term and
giving birth okay couple things here of
course
okay first up they say no incisions to
be made does that include to the baby
cuz sometimes the baby doesn't fit down
the vacuum you have and sometimes there
need to be some incisions to the baby so
let's make that clear there are
incisions sometimes may just not to the
mother again only made to the being with
a different heartbeat who's not a viable
life they said there's less
complications than childbirth and
delivering a baby I can't be the only
one who's missed this let's yes yes of
course because it is much harder to
create and to build than it is to
destroy do you know it would be
considered a complication when you're
delivering the baby do you know what be
considered a complication termination of
the banking that's the goal that
abortion if you're trying to deliver a
baby any harm injury or death to the
baby would be a complication you are
performing a procedure to carry out
those very things in an abortion was a
complicated delivery the baby yeah you
know the baby got the baby got hurt
there were some complications were there
complications and the abortion now we
killed it it's easier to throw up a baby
off a roof than it is to breastfeed it
comes with complications I don't know
where does the nipple I don't know just
throw it off the roof no complicated it
almost has a 100 percent success rate
it is remarkable this is why we can't
confess but we can't compare infant
mortality rates across different nations
either because we have different
standards well here you have a different
standard what constitutes a complication
apparently not the killing of a baby
ship I can't people they do some more
sleight-of-hand tricks let's let's watch
this after an abortion it is normal to
feel a range of
emotions but according to a study of
women who have had an abortion
the vast majority deemed it the right
okay let's pause here
do you notice where that line stops
right for her stop over three years is
what they don't include meaning like she
says a study one singular study showed
that women felt the abortion was the
right decision and didn't have feelings
of guilt within three years of the
abortion why do you pick that why do you
pick only within three so what about
five years what about ten years
what about twenty years down the line do
these not only pick specifically within
three years and it gets worse the longer
we go on with this BuzzFeed video
despite the music that they bought the
copyrights to your budget there's a
study actually out there no I again I
can't say this is definitive but
certainly more than one of their stays a
study that was conducted more long-term
that showed five years after women had
an abortion they were twice as likely to
feel guilt than women who had
miscarriages so there are Studies on
both sides but again it's important is
they porn to understand when they
provide a definitive source and then say
by the way as a caveat here and it
talked about the rightness of her
decision I don't know that that speaks
to the mental state it just thinks oh
yeah no I made the right decision you
can really feel bad and go no it was the
right decision for me but I still feel
bad about mental health and depression
or actual mental afflictions which is
something that they address next but
watch for it and a study published in
2016 found that the risk of mental
health problems is no greater for women
who have had an abortion then for women
who have given birth after attempting to
obtain an abortion okay I don't know if
you caught that when I first watched it
I skimmed through this because of course
you assume okay they said that women
didn't have any more in you know any
increased risk of mental illness of who
had abortion in women who didn't
important okay no no no no they say
there's no increased incidence of
depression or mental illness between
women who've had abortions and between
women who've tried abortions but failed
what is that the comparison
Colome is abortion column B also
abortion the rates are the same why
don't we have a column a abortion and
all failed abortions and column B no
abortions
don't you have a baseline that's kind of
what's important for example in the gold
standard at double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical style
clinical trial you have a baseline and
then you add in placebo in the drug
there's no baseline in BuzzFeed's world
where women don't have abortions and you
know why they draw this comparison
because actually and again we won't say
definitively as BuzzFeed does watch
their video but I think a case can be
made there are multitude of studies that
show women who have had abortions are
attempted have a significantly one of
them shows that women who have had an
abortion experienced in 81 percent
higher risk of mental health problems
some would call that significantly some
would call it statistically significant
yeah again you need to have a graph and
you find a cause right to find a cause
II okay abortions does that increase
mental health
I don't know how could you possibly we
talked with us about seeking truth again
if you're pro-life or pro-choice can we
acknowledge here that clearly BuzzFeed
is not even remotely attempting to seek
truth now no comparing abortions versus
abortions that didn't work out to tell
you see there's no more increased chance
of mount tell health issues really why
well everyone who's had an abortion has
about the same into health issues what
about those who didn't have abortions we
didn't care what these people failed at
abortions they did they weren't they
were they weren't good at them hey if
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you didn't like this video you should
subscribe anyway because then you can
watch the next video and what you can do
is down vote it and leave a comment
that's really negative you know
particularly if it's something like I
don't know maybe anti somatic even
though I'm not Jewish or something about
my hair or something about my weird nose
just leave a really negative comments
that everyone else around can act like
they care